[applause]
Gibbs: Thanks.
You know, that actually
ends our tour
through our end to end
Java support for App Engine
and our campfire one tonight.
Now what have I shown you
this evening?
What have we talked about?
Well, I talked about
some new features
that we put out
for App Engine,
namely the ability to purchase
additional resources,
our cron support
for scheduled tasks,
the ability to import and export
large amounts of data,
and the ability
to access data
that's behind the firewall.
Then I told you
a little bit more
about our early look
at end to end Java support.
That includes Java Runtime
for App Engine,
our Google Web Toolkit support
for building your UI,
and the Eclipse integration
which ties it all together.
Finally then
I showed you some demos,
and I also brought up
some demos from partners
who are using this stuff
in the real world
to solve real-world problems.
Now we think we've made a lot
of progress with App Engine
over the past year.
We know that we still
have lots left to do.
There's a lot of tasks
in front of us
and a lot of things
we need to solve.
And that's why this early--
That's why
our Java release tonight
is an early look.
We know it's not yet complete,
particularly,
as I've mentioned,
for a lot of software libraries
and frameworks,
we think they're gonna
take some adjustments
to get them running smoothly
on App Engine.
But we think
the best way to do that
is to put the software
in your hands
so you can use it
and tell us what works
and what doesn't
and help us fix it.
So tonight we're opening
the early look
at Java support and App Engine
to the first 10,000 developers
who sign up.
After that,
we'll be letting in more people
in the coming months.
And finally,
when we're ready,
and we think it's ready
for everyone,
we'll open up sign-ups
to the world.
So please, log in,
sign up, give it a try,
and let us know
what you think
about our Java support
for App Engine.
And that's pretty much it.
Now I have one other thing
I wanted to mention,
which is our Google--
plug for Google I/O,
our developer conference
coming up in May.
There'll be two days
packed full of sessions
about App Engine,
Google Web Toolkit,
and other technologies
seen tonight.
And they've also told me
that for those of you
who are here in person,
in the audience,
that underneath your chairs
some of them have
a golden ticket,
which will give you
admission for two people
to Google I/O.
So you can check for that.
And otherwise, thank you,
everyone, for coming out,
and please join me
for some birthday cake.
[applause]
[fiddle music]